Hello I'm Terry, Terry Pierce
and I've been making telescope mirrors for quite a number of years now, more than forty.
And I run telescope making classes to show people how to do the same thing.
When we're talking about making a mirror,
the opticians hundreds and hundreds of hundreds of years ago,
used different grades of sand which is nowadays called really Emery powder.
So, they would take their metal mirror, they would grind it to curve with the coarse grinding sand.
They would make it smoother and smoother with finer and finer grains of sand,
until they had a very very smooth
surface.
By the time you've finished and you're on the very finest grinding powders
it's unbelievably smooth, beautiful smooth silky finish to it.
They would then have an absorbent surface like pitch or even paper or silk or taffeta.
So the idea is, you put the pitch onto the grinding tool or a similar circular disc.
That pitch is moulded to match the curve of your mirror that you've ground very finely.
Once that pitch is hard and set you put
your very very fine polishing powder onto your mirror,
and you start polishing.
The powder beds into the pitch. It doesn't roll around it just sits there
and microscopically it acts like a plane and it would make the surface go shiny again.
You are aiming to make an optical surface which is accurate to about a millionth of an inch.
To polish a mirror is at least four, five, six hours of work.
The one thing you must do
is not to keep looking at the clock
because what you think is ten minutes is
only one minute passed.
There are various mentions of mirror
makers, earlier mirror makers,
even Herschel for example, as far as I can
gather, once he'd got started on
polishing a mirror he dare not stop and he'd work ten, twelve, sixteen hours without stopping.
With his sister helping and feeding him while he carried on polishing away on his mirror
to get this absolute perfect optical finish.
A mirror the size of the one we are making here
was the size of the one that Herschel
used to discover the planet Uranus with
and a little disk that size properly
made if you point it at the moon that we
show you craters on the moon no more
than the mile across, and it will show
you cracks on the moon probably about as
wide as the River Thames.
And all from a little polished piece of piece of metal. Cast, ground and polished by hand.